What if I was to tell you
that a game of peekaboo
could change the world?
Thanks to scientists,
we now know just how important
the first fiveyears are for
our health and development,
especially our brains.
Our healthy development
depends on these top five things,
One, connecting;
two, talking;
three, playing;
four, a healthyhome,
five; community.
All of this helps our brains
and us reach our full potential.
So what’s something you can do
that can really make a difference?
Scientists call itserve and return.
That’s just a grown-up way of saying
each time you talk to us,
playwith us,
make us laugh,
it not only builds and
strengthens our relationships
and mentalhealth,
it actually teaches us some of
the most important life skills.
Imagine the differencewe could make
if everyone everywhere did this.